[Music]
hi everyone I'm Heath black I'm the
managing director of product at signal
fire and let's actually take a quick
step back and ask uh why am I here uh so
before I got involved in Tech I actually
went and got a master's in Irish
literature of all things uh both of my
sons are named after Irish writers and
uh you're going to see how this actually
weaves into the presentation a little
bit later when you get a degree like
Irish literature you have to get
creative in how you actually use it in
2009 I got involved in uh some startups
and I helped ship the first ever
conversational chatbot at a company
called
chirpify uh I then went and worked at a
company called imz where we were trying
to build a Reddit competitor but a lot
nicer and then I actually went and
joined Reddit where I worked on
experimental business lines and trust
and safety
tools and I followed that experience up
by going to meta where I shipped meta's
first assistant it was called M it lived
within messenger and then I was the uh
first product manager on the AI
assistant for their Ray bang glasses but
now I serve as a managing director of
product at signal fire so what does
signal fire do I like to say the signal
fire is actually the first VC built like
a tech company and what I mean by that
is the same way that you all go out and
interview customers to figure out
whether you're building the right thing
for them before you ship your product
signal fire interview 500 Founders to
understand the things that keep them up
at night and make them bang their head
against the wall all day we then built
AI ml tools and our portfolio success
teams entirely around those problems
going to Market recruiting building your
leadership skills and the ability to
launch your product but today we're
actually here to talk about uh some
things that we've learned from our
proprietary a IML platform beacon beacon
tracks over 650 million employees 20 or
80 million companies and 200 million
open- Source
projects and with all of that
information we build a variety of
proprietary ranking systems and Market
insights that we can then use to power
our firm so that we can move at startup
speed but then also to support the
companies that we invest in
today's Focus we're going to be using
some of the data from Beacon to figure
out how to filter the right
people to find them in the right
locations to nail the right timing and
then finally to close them with the
right narrative so let's first start
with
filters when I think about recruiting I
think about it in terms of like what
filters would I apply to the people that
are on my team and that I want on my
team
Beacon gives people the tools to apply
these filters as they search but the
reality is if you don't know what
filters you need to apply you're not
going to find the right people so here's
some interesting trends that we've seen
that change how we
filter over the past you know decade or
so we've seen a Stark deenal isation in
ai ai startups are hiring more Engineers
without phds or prestigious schooling
than ever before in 2015
27% of engineer hires were from top
schools and 16% had
phds in 2023 those numbers were 15% and
7% this is about a 50% decline for both
of these numbers over that period of
time and you're probably saying that
doesn't sound right what about for
things like research scientists they've
got to have phds right and you know
you're not entirely wrong about 40% of
research scientists have advanced
degrees now this is not PhD is simply
Advanced degrees and even still it makes
up less than half of the people that
serve in research scientist roles
today from my standpoint this isn't too
surprising because there's been a slight
shift in the market since 2015 in 2015
we were really focused on the the kind
of ml research side of things the
foundational side of things whereas
today a lot of the work is about
applying that to the real world usage of
that model it's ml Ops Pro like product
like software experience is
understanding how users interact with
the thing that you're
building and with the shift from
credentials we've also seen this really
interesting people Mobility over this
period of time if you look on the left
side here historically a lot of the AI
Talent was centered on these companies
the Googles the Ubers the the metas the
apples and over this period of time
they've shifted to nine companies that
we call the aiv league the companies on
the right here have seen a massive
concentration of talent over this period
of time it's really interesting because
we generated this last year shortly
after that inflection was acquired so
one of the key things that I want us to
take away from here is that the market
is constantly moving so we have to
constantly be assessing where that
market is Shifting and the interesting
thing as well is that all the companies
on the left side of the screen are now
fighting viciously to get people from
the right side of the screen rather than
the other way
around but one of the key things is not
just knowing where people are going it's
about where they're coming from
this graph shows you net employee
movement between different aiv League
companies so to speak as you can see at
the top open AI has a positive flow of
people from Deep Mind whereas cohere
actually has a a negative Trend knowing
where people come from and where they're
going is essential in ensuring that you
are filtering for the right people as
you look for PE like you know building
out your
teams so the takeaway here is that work
experience has always been important but
it now far surpasses education in terms
of the main aspect that you should be
looking at here don't just rely on the
credentials that someone has you should
instead look at the body of work that
they've compiled for new workers you can
still look at their body of work what
are their open source contributions what
have they built outside of class the
reality is exper experience and what
you're building matters more than where
you get a degree secondly you should be
asking yourself do I need a PhD
researcher for the role that I'm hiring
or will a really awesome engineer with
experience
suffice and then the third is that you
should actually consider removing
academic requirements from your job
postings or maybe making them soft so to
speak because this will ensure that your
top of funnel is getting the people that
have the experience you need more so
than the
education now let's talk about the next
aspect which is location I'm sure many
of you have seen the debates on Twitter
that San Francisco is clearly dead and
so we wanted to know is
it interestingly the answer is no it's
not dead San Francisco makes up about
29% of all startup engineers now this is
slightly down from highs of 2013 when it
was at 33% but it's up ticking again
since
2021 New York and Seattle have also been
pretty impressive as they've both
doubled the market share of Engineers
that they have over that period of time
if we were to zoom out and look at big
Tech 50% of big Tech Engineers still
reside in the San Francisco Bay area but
what about AI specifically
well San Francisco is still leading the
pack 20 or 35% of all engineers in AI
reside within San Francisco Seattle
makes up about 22% New York makes up
about 10% so San Francisco makes up more
than both of those cities combined but
if you actually look at this slide and
compare it with the data that I showed
in the previous slide you'll see
that these these markets are all
punching well above their weight in
terms of AI hiring and AI Talent where
they had a smaller number in the
previous slide they have a much larger
number in this one so the talent is
concentrating in these threey key
markets today now this isn't terribly
surprising for me because San Francisco
makes up nearly 38% of all early stage
funding into AI startups and the
interesting thing about this is that San
Francisco only has 26% of all early
stage funding in the United States total
so not only is San Francisco punching
above its weight in terms of AI Talent
is punching above his way in terms of
the funding that is going to AI
companies
today so the takeaway here is that
Twitter doesn't determine whether a
market is dead data does location still
matters even in a highly distributed
world that we live in today San
Francisco Seattle and New York are the
premier locations for AI Talent today
and so your job is to watch the location
and funding markets to see where talent
and capital is Flowing as another way to
filter and find the right
people now let's talk about timing
finding the right person has as much to
do with time as it does
Talent at the airport on the way here it
was a mere matter of minutes that
separated me catching my flight or
sitting in the lobby sadly like Charlie
Brown a fraction of a second is the
difference between a home run to right
field or a foul ball in the bleachers
for me timing means two different things
first it means finding people when they
are most likely to leave secondly it
means finding people that really are
going to have a pinion to join a company
at your stage and uplevel your team for
where you are today so let's talk about
timing we analyze some of those aiv
League companies to see their retention
rates if you're on this slide I'm sorry
if the if the information uh offends you
at all but anthropic is leading the pack
with about a 66% 4year retention rate
while perplexity hovers around 44% or so
43% this is just a small slice of the
world as is constantly changing but the
reality is understanding retention helps
you know when you're likely to be able
to get someone to answer that message
that you send to them it effectively
creates a poach ability score so to
speak of your ability to land that
person but in addition to retention we
actually study the behavior of different
Generations they act
differently in 2023 nearly
27% of all gen Z left their job
if you compare this with Gen X that's
actually more than two times as much as
Gen X and if you were to look at the
fact that within four years after
graduating gen Z has about 2.2 jobs
whereas Gen X has
1.1 and so some of this has to do with
the fact that genz is actually getting
promoted at a slower rate some of it
might be causing those slower promotions
some of it has to do with the layoff
Market that took place over that period
of time but if you ask me a lot of it
has to come down to the penchant for
people to take risk and bet on
themselves j z likes that
risk but it's not just retention and
it's not just the generation you were
born into you need to know when people
work at different companies being on the
New York Knicks in 1973
is very different from being on the New
York Knicks in
2018 one of those teams held up a
championship trophy and the other team
had the worst record in their franchises
history so as signal fire we built this
cool tool we call it historical
composition and it actually shows all of
the startups that we invest in a
snapshot of the companies that they
admire at different points in time what
did their org structure look like at
that point in time who are the sales
leaders that took them from 1 million to
10 million who were the first three
Engineers on their team when they
shipped that key product that I'm trying
to beat now these things are going to
help you
identify the risk profile people have
are they going to join a company at your
stage it's going to Mo like help you
understand the motivations that they
have but it's also going to help you
understand whether they're a potential
10x higher which you need to make in
order to take your company to the next
stage so the takeaway here is that you
have to understand timing both from an
Outreach and an impact standpoint you
should know when your competitors or the
companies that you admire most are
likely to lose other people you should
track the people that work at those
companies profiles to see whether there
are changes made to it over that period
of time studying the patterns of
different Generations or segments of the
population will help you understand how
they change jobs and finally you you
need to know when people join and leave
companies because that will help you
identify your 10xers and help you
identify people that are likely to join
company at your stage now this is where
I finally get to use that literature
degree narrative one of my favorite
writers Kurt Von has this awesome
visualization for the shape of stories
if you look at the bottom left here on
the xais you have beginning and end and
on the Y AIS you have ill Fortune
leading up to Good Fortune so the bottom
left here is bronze kafka's
metamorphosis Gregor samso wakes up a
bug and everything goes downhill from
there on the top right you have a man
walking down the street and he falls
into a pothole but then he works him uh
works his way out but my favorite is
Cinderella she's on the bottom right
over here things start pretty crummy for
her sisters are evil she has to do a
bunch of work then uh some magic happens
and she gets invited to this ball meets
a beautiful man they fall in love and
then what happens the clock strikes 12
she falls off a cliff but then through a
series of fortunate events things lead
to Eternal bliss now I'm not telling you
that you need to preach the depths of
Despair that your company is in or has
gone through but you do need to
understand the triumphs that you've had
why you are where you are today where
your Arc is going the reason for that is
because historically pay and Equity were
the two components that we use for
narrative but we can't rely on those
solely
anymore why from November 2022 to
November 2024 we saw a
1.6% increase in the average tech salary
and a precipitous decline in the amount
of equity granted but I have some really
bad news for the folks in this room it's
even worse for ai ai Engineers are the
hot ticket for this year they command a
5% salary premium and 10 to 20% Equity
premium over other engineering roles so
what was already expensive is getting
even more expensive for us so if we rely
our entire narrative on that we're
relying on things that we might not be
able to afford so salary as a sole
selling point has got to
go Equity was that other thing that we
used to dangle to get people to buy into
what we were doing as a company but
we've seen a precipitous decline in the
amount of people that are exercising
vested
shares in Q2 of 2024 33% of people
exercised the shares that they had
vested this is down from
55% a couple years earlier a lot of this
is driven by concerns over uh valuations
that might be a little bit too high
concerns about the cost of liquid
Capital to exercise these shares and
concerns about the market shifting which
it does every 3 weeks in AI Equity can't
be the only other thing that we're
relying
on we have to get to a point where we're
not just focusing on money and Equity we
have to have things like a close-knit
environment with working with the
founders collaborative teams speed and
the lack of friction to actually get
stuff done a big mission the ability to
grow your mind and your career
opportunities markets that are
exploding and solving complex problems
you need to understand what all these
things are for your company in order to
not rely wholeheartedly on salary and
Equity as a narrative so to summarize in
a world where so many companies are
fishing in the same engineering Pond
recruiting data can give you an edge
these are just a few examples but in the
same way that you use data to build your
product both your models and the kind of
analysis of that product you should be
assessing data to build your team your
team is your most valuable product that
you have what we've seen is that decred
dential isation is happening so you need
to filter accordingly location still
matters so watch where people move data
can help you identify the right time to
reach out to people and it can help you
identify the right time that people have
been at different
companies and all of this is going to
help you craft a better narrative so if
you can filter if you can time if you
can find the right location and you can
have a good narrative you're going to do
a much better job if you're on the other
side of the coin and you're actually
looking for work you should know where
the people you admire go not just the
companies but the space you should watch
how long they stay there this will help
you know how they're treated whether
they think the space is going to be
fruitful and then finally you should
know what you want in that Arc of your
career I'll be out in the lobby a little
bit later thanks for your time
[Music]